In the world of See,
you can be the queen,
you can be a leader of a tribe,
you can be a warrior.
Each individual is
treated as an equal in our show.
I gotta do something as an actor
that i’ve never done before.
I’ve worked so hard to
play a character like this.
It was just incredible
to work with Joe.
He’s a producer and he’s blind.
And he’s there to further
the development of the
characters in the
best way possible.
Heres Joe Strechay to
give you some more advice.
It’s beautiful to have
someone like Joe
to help me through it.
We wanted to make sure
we were representing
our community positively.
So we looked at
the littlest behaviors
and how characters who
are blind move in the world.
I went in completely openminded.
And Joe will come up
and give me his notes
and I’ll say,
“I just never even
thought about it that way.”
We tried to do everything we can
to make sure that
this feels authentic
for the blind community
and Joe is key in that.
We have numerous actors who
are blind or low vision
and we want to make
sure that their needs
are met when they come to work.
This was amazing.
It was just such an experience.
I was treated
just with the
utmost care and respect.
Everyone has such
a good relationship,
and here, everyone’s like,
“you’re an actor,
you’re with us.”
We fight for our families!
We fight for our freedom!
[Cheers]
We try to make sure
that our characters,
who are blind,
aren’t using
non-verbal communication.
You know, like,
even nodding the head yes
or shaking the head no.
We’re gonna use our
ears to listen, right?
We’re not looking at him speak,
we’re listening to
him speak, right?
Physical gestures mean
very little in this world.
If you’re moving your hands,
it should be purposeful around
grabbing something,
touching something,
making a sound with your hands.
[Bells Ring]
They’ve done such a
great job in the way
they portray blindness
or visual impairments.
Joe started to teach me
about echo location.
You make sound.
[Clicks]
♪♪
And then, find out
the size of a room.
Beautiful room.
Where people are.
I had no idea that was
something that people could do.
Everything is inceptionally
designed to be
authentic to what
in a world would be like,
if most of the world
didn’t have sight.
The things we
built are beautiful,
but there also a lot
of logic built in.
Like putting tap lines down
the middle of the road
to get their direction
so they find a path.
The plates had individual little
grooves around the edge
of the chargers so that
the staff can acualy
figure out where
the table setting is
in the wedding the ribbon
hadbells on them so that
everyone could here
the reaction.
[Cheers]
With wardrobe
it forces you to use your other
sences for fabrics,
for touches, for texture
and then also
does it make sound.
I was really proud of everyone.
How hard everyone trained.
We work with every performer
to help bring them in
the world of See.
And then the team really
creates something beautiful.